hello in welcome
today's lecture which is brought to you
by
program in science and humanities here
at Yale University and by the Yale
University pointer fellowship in
journalism the mission of the Frankie
program is to support lectures events
performances and activities that bring
diverse audiences together to explore
the interface between science humanities
and our culture I'm excited about
today's event which I hope sure will do
exactly that as always I want to thank
Gary Tomlinson and the Whitney
Humanities Center for their support and
providing this marvelous home for the
Frankie program and I also want to thank
rich and Barbara Frankie for their
generous support for the program and for
their ongoing vision of a Yale community
that is more convivial intellectually
exciting and adventurous we all benefit
from it today it's my pleasure to
introduce our speaker Richard Preston
Preston did his undergraduate work at
Pomona and English and got his PhD in
English from Princeton University where
he studied 19th century American
non-fiction writing he's the author of
nine books on a variety of topics
including infectious disease as we know
redwoods a novel and a children's story
and of course is the author of many
nonfiction pieces for the New Yorker
magazine including a piece just last
week entitled inside the Ebola Wars in
1995 Preston published the hot zone
about the Ebola virus and an accidental
outbreak of the virus in a colony of
research monkeys in Reston Virginia in
the 1980s the hot zone sold millions of
copies and terrified millions of readers
for example novelist Stephen King wrote
the first chapter of the hot zone is one
of the most horrifying things I've ever
read and then it gets worse
I'm also sure that the hot zone inspired
many of its readers to consider and
pursue careers in epidemiology biology
and public health that fascination is a
fuels curiosity and a lot of what we
know today
the most recent massive outbreak of
Ebola occurring for the first time in in
West Africa has once again propelled the
hot zone back onto the national
bestseller list twenty years after its
publication now as an evolutionary
biologist I have always had a particular
fascination for the insidious ingenuity
of infectious disease and for the
dynamics of epidemic infection and and
so it's it's a pleasure to bring this
element to the Frankie program to
discuss it today and so I'm happy that
we have the opportunity and the
foresight to bring Richard Preston here
to talk to us today in this very timely
lecture his talk is entitled Ebola
breakout from the hot zone and please
join me in welcoming Richard Preston
thank you Rick
it's really a real pleasure and a
delight to be here even in the context
of Ebola I want to tell you I want to
start by telling you a story about Ebola
because Ebola is not just a virus it's
also a human problem but I also wanted
to let you know that I'm going to try to
keep my remarks remarks brief enough so
that we have a little bit of time for
Q&A afterwards there you know as Rick
pointed out my expertise is in English
literature and there are surely people
in this room who know more about Ebola
virus epidemiology and molecular biology
than I do
and it would be really fun to invite the
Yale community as a whole to get into a
discussion about some of the things that
I'm going to be presenting and and talk
a bit about Ebola and I will try to
answer whatever questions you may have
and there may be people in the room who
can answer them better than I can
now the Ebola virus has probably been
breaking into the human species since
time immemorial and small outbreaks in
Equatorial Africa the virus was never
able to establish a firm foothold in the
human species as a new host it lives
somewhere in Equatorial Africa in some
unknown creature possibly a bat or it
may well live in some parasite of the
bat such as a wingless fly a tick or a
mite that lives on the body of the bat
and is the actual carrier of Ebola we
simply don't know that isn't known in
1976 in a small up country rural
Hospital in yam buku and what was then
as I hear now the Democratic Republic of
Congo Ebola surfaced and came to the
notice of doctors for the first time
they didn't know at the time what it was
all they knew was that it was an
exceedingly lethal infectious disease
presumably a virus and it got into the
staff of the Ambu ku hospital one of the
victims was sister Beata a Belgian nun
who worked there and here we see her
just prior to 1976 in a log canoe on the
Ebola River waving goodbye this is the
last known photograph of sister Beata
the virus got into the medical staff of
the buku hospital we don't know who
patient zero was we don't know where it
came from but it raced through the staff
and it killed a number of people we see
here the gentleman with the beard in the
glasses is father lewton's a priest and
when sister Beata Lay Dying he gave her
the last rites she was weeping at the
time and one of the things that happens
with some cases of Ebola is you can get
tiny pinpoint hemorrhages on the the
rims of the eyelids apparently she had
blood on her eyelids and the blood
leached into the tears running down her
face
father Lutins began weeping while he was
giving her the last rites he he took out
his handkerchief and he he wiped the
tears from her face and then he wiped
the tears from his own face and he was
dead 14 days later at first
international health authorities had
absolutely no idea what was going on in
yam buku but it was extremely alarming
and virus experts from around the world
began getting teams together and going
in and one of the one of the very first
people in fact the first medical doctor
from the outside world to reach yam buku
was a Belgian physician by the name of
Jean Francois RuPaul he was a young
doctor he had never been posted to the
field before and this was his first
major outbreak he he had a good deal of
difficulty reaching yam buku when he
finally got there he arrived at night
and he went into the building he found
that that essentially most of the
medical staff was dead and the patients
that had been there had left had been
too frightened he walked into the
obstetrical ward in the operating room
Ebola virus is particularly devastating
for pregnant women it it will induce a
spontaneous abortion or miscarriage
accompanied by profuse hemorrhage in
which the the infant dies and the mother
typically dies as well so when dr. Roopa
went into the into the obstetric ward he
found pools of blood all over the floor
and used surgical sponges saturated with
blood all over the place and the Orr was
even worse and we're talking about very
very rudimentary Hospital equipped with
very little of what what we know of as
you know effective modern tools and
techniques so he realized very quickly
that these that these areas were
presumably laden with some unknown virus
Ebola at that time did not have a name
nobody knew anything about its
characteristics as an organism it was
assumed to be a virus not bacterial no
it nobody had any idea how it was
transmitted from person to person but it
was obvious that it caused hemorrhaging
in some patients and had an extremely
high case fatality rate the reported
case fatality rate in that early
outbreak in yam buku is something around
90% 9 out of 10 were said to die
one wonders really if that figure is it
all accurate it's just hard to say I
don't think there was any really careful
epidemiology done in any event
jean-francois loophole went to bed in a
small bungalow next to the hospital that
night and he reported later that my
first night was calm it was a night of
quiet and silence because people were
dead or they had fled
but then at five o'clock in the morning
a woman was brought in and she was in
childbirth and she was in terrible
distress she was shaking with fever she
had a very high fever and she was
hemorrhaging profusely from her birth
canal
rupal was the only doctor on the scene
who was able to make decisions or do
anything he the obstetric award was
clearly not the place for this woman so
they set up a table on the porch in
front and he had a couple of flashlights
and he turned those on for illumination
and then the woman was lying on the
table with nurses around there were
several nurses who had stayed despite
the obvious danger to themselves by this
point the remaining staff understood
that their lives were in jeopardy by
simply being near patients and dr. rupal
then examined the woman and he quickly
he came to some determinations as a
doctor the first was that the woman was
in grave distress that she was at the
end of her rope and was likely to die if
nothing was done that the baby was in
breech was presenting the wrong way
the woman was hemorrhaging and in order
to save the life of the mother and the
baby he would have to perform a
procedure however a cesarean section was
completely out of the question
she couldn't be brought into the into
the obstetrical ward or the o.r and in
any event he had no anesthetic there
were no no anesthetics available there
were only the light was just the light
of the flashlights and and he had rubber
gloves and he had a cloth gown so he
made a decision as a doctor to perform a
very old 19th century medical procedure
known as the Zarate procedure and it's
an alternative way of delivering a baby
he took a scalpel and the and he
separated the bones of the pubic
symphysis
now in the pelvis if you feel your
pelvis right down in front at the front
of the pelvic bone the bones join
together right here somewhat below your
navel it's a hard area but if you press
hard you can actually feel that the the
two front bones of the pelvis are joined
by a layer of very tough cartilage it's
a joint there and while the woman did
not have anesthetic he he then split her
pelvis through the cartilage like that
and then he had nurses open the woman's
legs and her whole pelvis came open like
this and then he brought the baby out
the baby was covered with blood
there was blood everywhere and the woman
was obviously in distress and then that
was when dr. RuPaul discovered that the
baby was in breathing arrest and without
thinking without thinking what he was
doing he tore off his surgical mask and
he placed the baby's face up to his face
and he rescued the baby's life he
breathed air into the baby's lungs and
he saved the baby and then he pulled
back and he suddenly realized what he
had done his face his eyes his mouth his
nose were covered with the babies and
the mother's blood his hands were
covered with blood and the nurses were
standing there in shock and one of them
said to him in a quiet voice doctor do
you realize what you have done and he
said I do now
now I'm telling the story because this
is what doctors in West Africa have been
facing today and it's a situation where
if you are a trained physician you move
in and you do what you have to do you do
what you've been trained to do and you
don't think about your own personal
safety
dr. RuPaul later reported this was the
only time in my medical career that I
was not just afraid but felt and lived
real terror he survived as it turned out
the woman's fever was from malaria she
didn't have Ebola and he had saved the
life of the of the child and the mother
who went on to live completely normal
human existences ends a year now since
then Ebola virus has made another 23
appearances on the planet 20 of which
were outbreaks in which it was
transmitted from one person to another
and the total cumulative number of
deaths there has been about less than
2,000 the outbreaks tended to be small
and they tended to burn out quick
quickly and doctors after a while got a
sense of what I think was complacency
and there was a general consensus in the
medical community that Ebola virus was
not much of a threat and could be easily
controlled but Nature has a way of
surprising scientific people with if
you're a scientist and you make an
assumption that isn't really based on
sufficient data Nature has a way of
completely surprising you now this
recent outbreak began it seems on about
December 6th 2013 when a two year old
boy in a small village called melyandd
ooh in Guinea died of what we now know
was Ebola virus it was a type of Ebola
that appears to be a little bit
different than all the other ebolas that
have appeared later on I'm going to talk
a little bit about the genetics of
viruses an event of Ebola this
particular Ebola began to move and it
left the village and it moved jumping
from person to person to person setting
up what are known as chains of infection
now when a virus is making a so-called
trans-species jump into the human
species from some host species when a
virus is attempting so to speak to turn
the human species into a new host
the if you can talk about the goal of
the virus this is a little bit tricky
because the organism does not have
anything like a consciousness as we
would describe it and it has nothing
like intention as we would talk of
intention but what it does have is
biological sophistication and it is set
up genetically to be opportunistic the
goal of the virus is to set up endless
chains of infection in its new host
chains that are unbroken and never end
and in that sense the virus the the
virus which is making the trans species
jump which HIV did is making itself
immortal in its new human species its
new host something like 7,000 years ago
the smallpox virus did this smallpox is
thought to have once lived in some
natural host probably a rodent and
probably a rodent that lived on grain
and about 7,000 years ago was the first
time in the history of our species that
we were gathered in large numbers in
congregated in river valleys in the in
the Middle East and in China where you
had agglomerations of up to 200,000
people within a 14-day travel time of
one another the incubation period for
smallpox virus is up to 14 days and
epidemiologists who have done done the
math and done the computer simulations
have concluded that smallpox might have
been making these little jumps into the
human species but it was only with the
growth of agricultural concentrated
populations in river valleys and then
with grain silos with rodent explosions
explosions of rodent population living
on the grain that the virus was able to
become immortal in the human species and
smallpox maintained its immortality
until it was declared eradicated by the
World Health Organization in 1979
and it now lives only in laboratories in
a frozen state so Ebola virus is
somewhere in an earlier phase of an
attempt so to speak to make itself
immortal in the human species we have
some images this is from a year in 1976
and the images are pretty much like what
we're seeing today the guy that
discovered it Carl Johnson is still
active in Ebola research but the
question is what is Ebola anyway this is
an image of one of the very ons or
particles of Ebola the virus particle
looks like a strand of spaghetti and
it's composed of only seven structural
proteins that are knitted together into
this worm like spaghetti like shape
there are additional three proteins that
are enzymes that operate in various
stages of the replication process of the
virion the particle and right at the
center of the particle inside a kind of
a container made of coiled protein is a
strand of RNA which contains the genetic
code of the virus Ebola virus a one
recent sample of it they counted
eighteen thousand nine hundred and
seventy nine letters of RNA which is a
very small genome by the standards of
life the human genome is something like
3 billion letters of DNA and there are
orchids that have I believe up to 10 to
12 billion letters of DNA in their
genomes it would seem that there are
some orchids that are perhaps much more
complicated than human beings Ebola
virus is considered to be a biosafety
level 4 agent for which there is no
vaccine and no cure so if you're in a
laboratory you need to be wearing a very
high degree of bio protective gear in
order to be working with concentrated
amplified quantities of the virus
these are some photographs of this is a
beautiful photograph these are elephants
and Kitumba a v' which is thought to be
one of the hiding places of the Marburg
virus which is a cousin of Ebola when a
particle of Ebola gets inside a cell it
begins to replicate like mad inside the
cell and the replication cycle Peaks
about 18 hours after the first particle
enters the cell and essentially the the
virus turns that cell into a factory for
making a lot more Ebola virus particles
and the cell rounds up it gets a swollen
plumped up shape you can see a cell here
that is infected with Ebola and then the
very ons the particles begin growing out
of the cell like hair you can see them
doing this and one cell will produce
thousands and thousands of these
particles now one of the odd things
about Ebola is that the virus takes its
sweet time killing the cell that it's
coming out of these cells tend to last a
lot longer than a human cells that are
infected with HIV which die very quickly
once HIV is active in the cell so that
Ebola has this capability of really
keeping that host cell alive longer and
making more of itself out of that cell
in in West Africa well the the net
effect on a human is that as the virus
multiplies in the body as more and more
cells become infected and spew out
thousands and thousands of Ebola
particles the the titers of the virus in
the bloodstream that is that the density
or the quantity of particles in a
droplet of blood goes up astronomically
and at the at the end of an Ebola
infection
what happens is that the bloodstream is
really loaded with these particles
nobody really understands how a person
dies of Ebola virus but clinically we
know that the blood vessels begin to
leak and capillary Bloods
beds all through the body lose their
integrity the the blood vessel walls
just lose their integrity and blood and
blood plasma begin just seeping out of
the blood vessels this also for some
reason triggers clotting and the
clotting will continue you get something
called disseminated intravascular
coagulation or di C in which the blood
essentially throws tiny clots everywhere
in the body and then eventually the
clotting factors are used up and the
patient then can begin to have
hemorrhages and we'll have multiple
organ failure and go into shock and when
someone has died of Ebola it's really
hard to point to any particular cause of
death because you know the person has
had multiple organs shut down and
they're in shock massive loss of blood
pressure and so forth at the end of the
replication phase in a human being think
of a droplet of blood large enough to
make a little spot that covers perhaps a
fifth of your pinky fingernail and in
that droplet of blood there could easily
be between 100 million and 1 billion
particles of Ebola virus Ebola is
exquisitely infectious in direct contact
with blood and laboratory experiments
suggests that as few as a single
particle of Ebola virus if introduced
into the human bloodstream can cause a
fatal infection now
Ebola as the Ebola outbreak widened
hospitals in West Africa quickly became
overwhelmed with Ebola patients and one
of them was the Kenema government
hospital in Sierra Leone for many years
the Kenema government hospital had a
laboratory for investigating Lassa virus
which is another African hemorrhagic
fever virus that is devastating is
considered to be a biosafety level 4
agent because there is no vaccine for
Lassa and no reliable cure for it and a
number of American researchers including
this woman here pardis sabeti who is an
assistant professor associate professor
at Harvard University and affiliated
with the broad institute of genomics at
Harvard and MIT in Cambridge have been
working there for years doing research
on Ebola I'm sorry on Lhasa here we have
the Broad Institute where they do
genetic sequencing genome acceding of
all kinds of organisms pardis sabeti and
a colleague of hers named Steven Geyer
are the subjects are among the subjects
of my recent New Yorker article about
the Ebola outbreak sabeti is quite a
remarkable scientist among other things
she is a singer and a songwriter for an
indie band thousand days and they had to
put their fourth album on hold due to /
deesis involvement in the Ebola outbreak
and she began working with physicians at
the Kenema hospital including Sheikh
Omar Khan who was running the the Lasser
research unit and was that essentially
the chief physician at at the Kenema
hospital and early on the people at MIT
and Harvard and dr. Khan
decided that it would be a really good
idea to get genome sequencing of this
new Ebola and the idea was to find out
how the virus is mutating Ebola is
certainly mutating as it passes from one
person to the next because the genetic
code of Ebola is in RNA RNA viruses are
known to make errors when they copy
themselves errors of copying and it's a
lot like monks who copied medieval
manuscripts by hand as they copied and
copied and copied they introduced small
changes in words and letters and as time
goes by the text changes and as Ebola
moves from one person to the next in
these chains of infection and these
generations of infection it's being
subjected to ferocious natural selection
in which each person who is infected
with Ebola may have multiple genomes of
Ebola in their body by the time the
infection Peaks out in other words the
virus may mutate inside the body of a
single individual and and the question
is if Ebola is mutating and we know it
is mutating exactly how is it changing
how is it changing in response to the
conditions it's experiencing in the
human body and what could happen to it
and there's a general concern that that
the longer this outbreak goes on and the
longer that Ebola virus is exposed to
the human body and it's replicating and
replicating in vast numbers and then
going from one person to the next that
you set up statistically a chance of a
mutation that could make the virus far
more contagious in humans more easily to
spread from one person to the next
so sabeti in this lab and dr. Khan began
working on trying to get blood samples
of patients with Ebola and then getting
the samples over here to the United
States to the Broad Institute where they
could be sequenced in red one of the key
players here was the lady on the left
here nurse Ambala Fani she was the head
nurse at the Kenema hospital she was a
small person and a complete dynamo who
always wore a starched white uniform
except when she was in biohazard gear
dealing with you with a lass of patience
and then Ebola patients in any case in
May 23rd of this year a woman arrived in
Kenema and she was in she was having a
miscarriage and hemorrhaging and dr.
Cahn suspected that in fact she might
have Ebola they tested her blood and
they found out that indeed she was
positive for Ebola and then a dr. Cohn
and his colleagues and nurse Bonnie
along with others at the Kenema Hospital
ended up collecting blood they collected
blood from discarded blood tubes that
were going to be incinerated in a
biohazard incinerator at the hospital
the reason for doing this is that it's
considered to be highly unethical to
take samples from a patient in a
clinical setting for research that's
that's an anathema to clinicians and to
researchers so essentially what they had
to do was they had to gather that the
the RNA the code of Ebola virus from
medical waste they brought these samples
over to the Broad Institute and I don't
know how many of you are familiar with
genome sequencing and how it works I
knew nothing about it before I went
there and interviewed people but Stephen
Geyer
who is the the genome guy there Stephen
Carr is an interesting fellow he
originally he's apparently a very
talented chef and he was offered a
chance to compete on the the Bravo show
Top Chef
and he turned it down and instead went
to Africa to do research on monkey pox
virus which is a cousin of smallpox but
he I think the reason him why he's a
good chef is also the reason why he's a
good molecular biologist he these people
are they tend to be extremely precise
with their hands and they tend to have a
sense of calmness and control when
they're dealing with small quantities of
liquid and complex recipes which is what
molecular biology is essentially all
about
so Dyer and his colleagues took these
initially they took 14 samples of human
blood that were infected with Ebola
virus from patients they they had a
technique whereby they could take this
this actually was blood plasma but it
was blood plasma that had a lot of
destroyed red blood cells in it because
if you take a blood sample from an Ebola
patient it's gonna look different it's
gonna look like a mess it's gonna look
like blood that it's very sick in fact
dead kind of blood with dead blood cells
in it anyway they took this medical
waste this horrible looking blood they
purify it and they do things like they
add simply ethyl alcohol you know
essentially purified vodka to this and
they can extract the RNA the RNA comes
out in solution and they end up with a
droplet called a library and the library
contained in this case trillions of
fragments of RNA of the fragments were
about 300 letters long they were
shattered RNA from a much longer from
many many genomes of Ebola and each
individual fragment was tagged with a
barcode of DNA of eight letters of DNA
that linked that fragment to one of 14
patients individual human beings who who
had been infected with Ebola virus
and this liquid droplet was about the
size of a raindrop no bigger than that
and it was in a little tiny micro titer
tube and then Stephen Geyer took it over
to the sequencing platform the machines
at the Broad Institute these genomic
sequencing machines that are each one
costs a million dollars and they're
about the size of a chest freezer and
there are 54 of them in the sequencing
core at the Broad Institute and the
staff in this place they take that
little droplet which is called a library
let's think about the amount of
information in that droplet of genetic
code the way Geyer described us to me
that each of these pieces of RNA with a
barcode on it
could be thought of as a book with a
cover on it that had an ISBN number on
it and however and this would represent
an ungodly number of piles of the
libraries Library of Congress this is
many many libraries of Congress in some
gigantic pile of books but the books are
unorganized they've never been read
nobody knows what's between the covers
and they're in a huge pile they're not
lined up on the shelves in proper order
and so in the sequencing core a
technician took about a tenth of that
rain drop an amount of liquid something
like a drop of moisture that hits your
face when you're walking through fog and
put that on a glass slide called a flow
cell and then the flow cell is put into
the business end of one of these
sequencing machines and then lasers
shine on the flow cell well-well-well
compounds liquid compounds are washed
over the flow cell and in a period of
about 24 hours they get the sequence of
more than a billion of these little
pieces of RNA and now they have a huge
amount of data it's all in a computer
and it's then put into these giant
supercomputing farms where all these
pieces of RNA are assembled because
they're all overlapping they're all they
all have little bits of code that fit
together like a jigsaw puzzle 24 hours
after that they had they had 12
completed finished genome sequences of
Ebola virus 12 varieties of the virus
and it had mutated in each of the cases
they could tell because of the way the
mutations were running they could tell
who had given the virus to whom they
were able to reconstruct a chain of
infection of these 14 individuals in
Sierra Leone and they were also able to
show that the virus had originated with
one human being presumably the little
boy and melian Doo who could well have
been infected with but one particle of
Ebola virus
this entire outbreak could at least in
theory have started with one particle of
ebola or if not one maybe just a few
they also found out that ebola that in
about half the cases of ebola moving
from one human being to the next there
was a significant mutation in the code
causing a slight but but measurable
change in a protein in the virus and
this has a direct effect on our ability
to fight Ebola because all of the drugs
and vaccines and tests that we have for
Ebola are all keyed into the genetic
code of the virus and if the genetic
code of the virus is changing then it
can become less visible to the tests the
tests won't elicit the virus as
successfully the vaccine might not work
as effectively the vaccines that are now
in development and the drugs are also
key to the to the very genetic code of
this organism meanwhile while this was
going on
pardis sabeti was terrified for whom our
con-con above all was a doctor he was a
completely committed doctor to his
patients and he stopped sleeping he
began working in the ebola war
at Kenema the wards became distressing
and horrible to work in as they filled
up with people some of the staff
understandably got too frightened to
come to work until finally dr. Conn was
working alone in wearing protective garb
called PPE which is a kind of a portable
spacesuit
along with nurse Ambala Fani and a few
other people and Joseph fair an American
epidemiologist went to Kenema to see how
dr. Khan was doing and he was shocked
and dismayed to see what was happening
there was a there was one bola there
were three wards at Kenema that were
completely stuffed with Ebola patients
and the largest was a big plastic tent
that had been erected by a relief agency
and inside the tent there were about 30
beds of a certain type common in Africa
known as a cholera bed a cholera bed has
a plastic mattress in a hole in the
center of the mattress and the patient
lies on the mattress and defecates
through the hole into a bucket because
people who have cholera have
uncontrollable watery diarrhea with
Ebola they can also have uncontrollable
diarrhea which is which is often enough
has a lot of blood in it and when Joseph
Farah looked in the window he saw who
mark on in there with one nurse and the
place was a nightmare everything that
can come out of a human body was all
over the floor and all over the
protective garb of dr. Khan and as I
said in direct contact a bola maybe
maybe lethally infectious with one
single particle many of the people who
became infected with Ebola in this
outbreak couldn't remember making any
mistakes at all they thought their gear
was good they thought the
decontamination process was precise but
they got Ebola anyway in any event one
day who marcon didn't come to work and
they found out that he was keeping
himself at home he had isolated himself
he was feeling ill
they noticed that for the for the a few
days previously dr. Khan had been taking
himself off alone uncharacteristically
and sitting in a plastic chair and
smoking a cigarette and looking off into
space he never smoked in the wards but
he was now and later they thought that
he he knew he was coming down with Ebola
and he wanted to protect the staff by
keeping himself away from them when they
sent somebody to his house they took a
blood sample and he was positive for
Ebola at that point dr. Khan decided
that he needed to get himself away from
Kenema because his presence as a patient
in the Ebola ward would be too
demoralizing for the remaining staff and
so he climbed into an ambulance which
took him for four or five hours over
these terrible rutted dirt roads to a
another clinic in a place called Kyla
hoon where he became sicker and sicker
in isolation in the Ebola ward now in
Kyla hoon there was a freezer and in the
freezer there was one human course of an
experimental drug that had never been
tested in humans called zmapp and the
the Sierra Leonean government regarded
Kumar Khan's illness as a national
crisis and they called in international
experts asking for help and the experts
became aware of the fact that the zmapp
drug was there in a freezer 25 feet away
from dr. Khan and they debated for three
days whether to give him the drug or not
and the considerations were you know
were very very difficult to work their
way through this was an experimental
drug he was an African doctor he was a
national hero if he was given the drug
and he died then he would be an African
doctor who had been killed by an
experimental drug administered by you
know doctors from the developed world
he might the drug might have no effect
on him
but if he died it would be blamed on the
drug on the other hand the drug might
save his life and then it would be well
if he got the drug why can't anybody
else have the drug and they went back
and forth and back and forth and
meanwhile dr. Khan didn't seem to be
that sick he seemed to be hanging in
there and so there was hope that he
would at least that he had a good chance
of just coming through naturally now the
thing about Ebola is that patients can
often look like they're doing all right
but then you can suddenly go into what
some what some people experts call the
crash where you all of a sudden go into
a startling decline and it can happen in
a matter of hours where you you just
lose blood pressure you have multiple
organ failure and you just die very fast
and in the end that is what happened to
dr. Khan the zmapp drug eventually ended
up with the to the two people working
for a Christian medical organization
called Samaritan's Purse dr. kent
brantly and nancy writebol an aide both
survived they split the dose of zmapp
and dr. Brantly in particular seemed to
his his symptoms were he seemed to be at
the point of death when the drug was
administered to him and he turned around
in a period of about three or four hours
on the night of July 31st this year and
when I was researching the article I
discovered that at the very moment that
Kent Brantly was was apparently being
saved by the zmapp drug was the moment
that the burial detail finished digging
the grave and burying Doctor Who mark on
in Kenema Sierra Leone now I'm thinking
of the words of William tee close dr.
William D close who died a couple of
years ago was the father of the actress
Glenn Close
he was an expert in Ebola virus he was
the head of the mama yamo Hospital in
Kinshasa Congo in 1976 and he was
involved firsthand in that first
outbreak of Ebola virus and he said to
me once if there are lessons to be
learned here they are human lessons this
is about people doing their duty
it's about doctors doing what has to be
done right now without a whole lot of
heroics have you ever been petrified
with fear where you have not where you
have no hope of control over your fate
if you're a medical worker when the die
is cast and you face Ebola the fear goes
away and you do what you have to do you
get to work this is what Doctor Who mark
on did I'm sure that in times to come
there will be bronze statues to him and
to nurse Ambala fani and the others who
died at Kenema but I think what we have
here is we have medical people who
sacrifice their lives for their patients
and not only that also sacrificed their
lives for science itself and when the
sabeti and guy our paper was finally
published in science magazine five of
the authors were deceased they were all
people who had died in the Ebola
outbreak in Kenema one of the authors
was dr. Cohn another aweso author was
nurse Ambala Fani
I'm going to leave it there I have more
but I see we're running a little short
on time and I thought it would be
wonderful to just open up the room to
questions and during the course of that
I might be able to tell you a little bit
more about the results as we now see
them in terms of the mutation rate of
Ebola and what Ebola is doing right now
in West Africa thank you very much
print these questions please use a
microphone any thoughts any questions
yeah yes there was an interesting spread
in the sunday New York Times about
people photographs of workers in Africa
including an American Stephen hatch from
Massachusetts my question is I gather
one or two people have survived in
America and knowing American medicine as
I do they had all the bells and whistles
they got a lot of transfusions however
one of the people in the photographs in
the New York Times a young African man a
survivor of Ebola do some people just
because they are unique whatever they've
got genetically does some people just
make it through the type of Ebola they
have or are the bells and whistles
absolutely necessary this is a really
good question and I don't think at this
point we really know the answer
fully we don't actually know why some
people survive an Ebola infection and
some do not and it seems pretty evident
that there is a genetic component that
some people just have a lucky you know
like a lucky roll of the dice in their
genes there were people who had tons of
contact with HIV never got it
also written up in the New York Times
and no one really knew why we never got
at least I never got an answer as to
what made them have no problem with it
but well I can tell you one thing if you
want to survive an infection with Ebola
this comes from unpublished oral data
that
pardis sabeti told me about you need to
be young if you are infected with ebola
here are the statistics for this
outbreak okay if you are if you are as
old as 35 to 40 the case fatality rate
goes up to 84 percent you're already too
old if you are aged about 43 to 45 the
case fatality rate is around 93 percent
if you are in your 50s or 60s you might
as well kiss yourself goodbye you know
the case fatality rate is probably going
to be close to 90 90 something percent
young people are surviving Ebola yes
Richard thanks so much for your talk um
you started off by speaking about how
you were going to talk so much about how
you were going to talk about the human
aspect the human story behind you bola
and I think you've done that so well and
I also wanted to see if you could just
speak for a moment about the human
animal stories behind zoonotic diseases
like Ebola and I'm thinking in
particular of course these zoonotic
diseases there they aren't created equal
they're very different in their effects
and how they're transmitted but they do
share this this human animal leap and
I'm thinking about culturally this is a
cultural question about the culture of
these diseases and in particular Ebola
rather than the science thinking of
diseases like SARS avian flu and the way
that we talk about those diseases in the
human animal connection there we tend to
think a lot more about you know sort of
what what what are the what are the
Chinese eating like what are these the
wrong things that they're eating that
they're getting these that the diseases
are coming into the human world from and
we don't hear as much about that with
Ebola
you know the fruit bats are a part of
this and that comes up in some of the
reporting that we see but we don't talk
about it as much and I'm just curious if
you've thought at all about that
difference and that the human animal
story there yeah that's really
interesting I think actually that's
that's correct we don't talk very much
about the human animal connection with
Ebola except that there are these
strictures you know you
don't eat bush meat you know that's
ridiculous the problem is that we don't
know what we don't know very much about
that the animal connects the connection
to the animal world we know that Ebola
is coming out of an animal host but in
these outbreaks in all of them the
patient the early patients patient zero
and the ones that follow patient zero
are dead and so when the epidemiologist
comes around to find out you know what
were you doing
did you eat a bat fruit bats are
supposed to taste delicious they're
supposed to be not bad at all did you
eat some bat did you kill a bat
did you kill something else did you get
a tick that was on the bat where was the
bat what kind of a bat you know or was
it actually a rodent that you ate or
where you know what was it you know the
you the epidemiologist simply run into
darkness because all of the early cases
were dead and they can't talk anymore
they can't tell you what they were doing
another thing that I think I do want to
address this a little bit which is the
the the great confusion there's been a
huge amount of confusion in the public
discourse about what airborne means and
whether air you know whether Ebola virus
could mutate you know and get into the
air and you know turn into some kind of
Andromeda Strain that's gonna wipe us
all out so eric lander the head of the
the road institute put it very
succinctly to me so ebola virus is
mutating the longer this outbreak goes
on the more chances this virus has to to
develop a mutation that would really be
dangerous for all of us but it doesn't
necessarily have to you know go into the
air in order to travel more effectively
from one human being to the next and the
way eric lander put it was can zebras
learn how to fly he said that's really
not the right question to ask the right
question to ask is can zebras learn how
run three times faster and Ebola could
certainly do that
there are unpublished results showing
that that in some Ebola patients of this
type of Ebola that we're seeing they're
getting up to ten times the number of
virus particles in their bloodstream
then have been seen typically in
previous outbreaks so the virus is going
to grow into tremendous profusion in
human bodies this doesn't necessarily
make you sicker but it might make you
more infectious because you're just
producing that many more particles
coming out of your body so that could be
an you know a favorable adaptation or a
favorable mutation for Ebola we just
don't know at this point and then in
terms of airborne there are really two
kinds of airborne with viruses there's
what's called droplet infection which is
where I mean yeah here we go I've got a
picture here this is this is somebody
sneezing and you can see the droplets
coming out of this guy's mouth okay
these are liquid droplets and they're of
a size that causes most of them to fall
to the ground in a distance of about a
meter maybe two meters at most so the
rule of thumb is when you were around
Ebola patients they could be throwing
liquid droplets into the air 40% of the
patients in this outbreak are coughing
coughing is apparently a major feature
of the Ebola virus disease that we're
seeing in West Africa today people could
easily be coughing particles of Ebola
small part you know small droplets of
blood but they're not going to go that
far through the air the other way that a
virus can move is the way the measles
virus moves
here's measles this is what it looks
like measles is part of the
morbillivirus family and in this case
the virus can travel through the air in
dried form the virus can survive drying
and it if it can put you know it can
essentially end up in small dried dust
particles that can travel 150 yards from
one person to the next person and then
get embedded deep into the lung
where the virus can then activate attach
itself to lung tissue and begin
replicating in a new host
so with true aerosol transmission like
this this is a measles and viruses from
the measles family are actually far more
dangerous than Ebola
because it's almost impossible in an
outbreak to really trace the the cases
in context because you know you can have
somebody you know hundred yards away who
gives it to somebody else and you know
that that's something that really alarms
a lot of people and the question about
the animal kingdom there there are these
morbillivirus live in animals and they
they have the potential of moving into
humans and they have done so in the
recent past yes general public what do
you think has been the role of American
media in coming has it been could you
describe this well actually I think the
media coverage in the United States has
been terrific the New York Times and The
Washington Post in particular have done
a really good job covering the Ebola
outbreak and you know they've had
reporters on the ground really detailing
the human suffering getting into the
questions of science I think the print
media has done a wonderful job I never
know about the you know the the video
media it's always hard the the video
media tends to depend very heavily on
the print media for stories in the
United States and they don't seem to
have a whole lot of time to really to
really get into things but in some in
some instances I've seen very good
reporting a CNN has done an excellent
job in terms of video media so I think
in general the media coverage of this
outbreak has been quite good very good
yeah yeah
yes again for your talk I was wondering
if you could talk a little bit about
some of your research methods when you
were gathering the information about
this and for The New Yorker article did
you go to these hospitals in West Africa
how did you get all this information
well this is a really great question I
mean I'm a writer and I love talking
about writing and it's a somewhat
different subject I mean I'm supposed to
be an area expert in Ebola right but
actually what I am is I'm an expert in
writing I'd love to talk about I've been
teaching some classes here at Yale it's
been a lot of fun in this particular
instance the way I do this is nonfiction
writing this is what we would call
narrative nonfiction and I typically
spend huge amounts of time with my
subjects I get to know them as
individuals very often people that I've
written about over the years become
lifelong friends it's just one of those
things that happens but when you spend a
lot of time with somebody taking a lot
of notes you end up learning a whole lot
more about that human being that ever
ends up in print all the skeletons in
the closet come out you know you find
out all about whatever medical problems
they have I'm typically I never write
about a person's medical issues unless
it's part of the story itself and I also
get I get the cadence of their voice in
my head until I can hear them in my
sleep I wake up in the middle of the
night hearing my subjects talk to me and
in in a number of my books for some
reason I go back to the same characters
in nonfiction so I think I may be one of
the only nonfiction writers I know of
who has a repertory cast
so Peter journaling for example the guy
who whiffed Ebola virus in the hot zone
you know and he later said that uh that
whiffing Ebola virus from a flask was
the second dumbest thing he ever did the
dumbest thing was to tell Richard
Preston about it
but Peter is indeed you know a good
friend of mine today
and he's come back again and again he's
been in Demon's in the freezer he was a
major character he he was a source for
two of my books without you know being
in the foreground and I'm now at work on
another book and I think Peter will be
back in that one as well
so I know this is a long way of
answering your question so it's a matter
of taking notes and getting to know my
subjects in this case I did not go to
West Africa I did all of my reporting at
MIT and also it'll an NIH laboratory in
Maryland and I never went to Africa I
will be going to Africa for the course
of the research on this book and I never
met who mark on and I never saw the
Kenema Hospital but what I did do was I
got to know members of his family he has
siblings brothers and sisters who live
in the United States and it's an
extraordinary family and I got a real
kind of feel for this guy just by
talking to the people who loved him so
that's how I did this particular piece
of research I don't know if that's an
answer or not and I'd love to talk about
right okay thank you yeah I was
wondering if you could comment on the
the ability of the world to be prepared
for this outbreak and whether you think
that I think that it's failure was
primarily maybe a scientific one to
under estimating the virus or maybe an
illogical one to to under estimating the
conditions in which it could have spread
well I think you know there's been a lot
of finger-pointing
over this outbreak and a lot of
discussion of you know the failure of
the World Health Organization to really
good on top of it and the failure of all
kinds of medical organizations and
governments to really understand what
was happening here I see it a little bit
differently you know I didn't you know
it would be only two I would love to be
able to get smug with you and say oh
well you know I
the hot zone and I saw this coming a
long time ago I'm sorry to tell you that
I'm not really able to do that in any
honest way I think this outbreak really
surprised people it's always easy in
retrospect and you know now we know I
mean got you know what would do we park
our brains at the door you know I mean
of course you know you just think about
you know these crowded urban
environments and you put a bola into a
crowded slum in West Africa or for that
matter if Ebola gets into Dhaka in
Bangladesh or anywhere in South Asia
where our hospitals are well known for
not having adequate infection control
you know Ebola could still it could very
easily leave West Africa but I see this
as not so much a failure on the part of
of the public health community but as a
natural disaster that just simply
overwhelmed us I see it in the same
terms as let's say a tsunami or an
earthquake like the Japanese tsunami
take that for example okay the Japanese
had been preparing for a long time for
tsunamis but they just didn't think of
everything and they didn't think just
how bad it was really going to be and a
lot of people died in the Japanese
tsunami and yeah they could have done
things better but in the end what we're
seeing I think is is essentially the the
impotence and the powerlessness of the
human species to really control its
destiny in the ecosystems of the planet
that that you know in the end if it
wasn't Ebola it's going to be something
else and personally I think that Ebola
is by no means the most dangerous virus
on the planet and in a way what's
happening with Ebola right now is an
excellent wake-up call for very worse
things that could happen and I see this
outbreak regardless of where it goes you
know I mean it could still go global or
we have epidemiologists right here in
this room we have one guy who's just
come back from Liberia I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this but he thinks that
the epidemic curve may already be
turning over in other words the number
of cases may be flattening out
we just don't know what the future holds
for Ebola it's very unpredictable but I
think what we can think about Ebola is
that it's a kind of case study Mother
Nature has given us a really interesting
case study in what can happen with an
emerging infectious disease when it
comes out of some some little host in
nature that we didn't think about I
don't know if that's really an answer to
your question but we have feel so let me
ask the corollary of that question if
you knowing what we know and then you
say well Ebola is now not just in one
urban area but it's in in several why do
you think been there for months why do
you think we're seeing as low a case
number as what we are I'm sorry could
you could you refresh us with your name
Ryan Boyka Ryan
Boyko Ryan Boyd oh yeah great thank you
so Ryan you just got back from Liberia
right yes yeah thank you for your work
Thanks
well I heard one one epidemiologist told
me that he he sees in this Ebola
outbreak he sees what he calls the
fireworks displays and he said we don't
really understand what Ebola is doing
but it it it goes off like a burst of
fireworks in some place like conakry the
capital of Guinea and then everything
goes dark and then the wards all of a
sudden there's nobody in the Ebola wards
you know where you know
weeks earlier there were a hundred
people another five and then he said you
know but it's like a fireworks display
and then things are dark and then
there's a bigger flash than before and
he doesn't understand this guy doesn't
understand what's actually happening
with Ebola outbreak why this is
happening do you have any insight into
this and and he told me that you know
after things looked like they were
totally under control in Conakry now all
of a sudden there's been a bigger flash
of Ebola in Conakry and there are more
cases than ever before in that city do
you have any sense of what's happening I
have a few guesses okay let's hear hum
so so for one behavior changes is a huge
factor and every single building in
Monrovia I mean even outside of the
nicer areas I mean even in the slums and
things you're they have hand-washing
stations where we're with you know water
with with a bit of detergent or bleach
in it they have you know and other
measures like that but and and nobody is
really you know there's no hand shaking
there's none of that going on not that
those behaviors necessarily in
particular are are responsible for
preventing too many infections but I
think that it's a testament to the fact
that it's just always on everybody's
mind and and at this point I don't think
that there's a lot of people who you
know there who don't believe that it's
real or don't believe that it's
transmitted by bodily fluids or those
kinds of things and I think that
regardless of what your customs are if
you see people dying in front of you
or your neighbors have seen people dying
in front of them that has a big impact
on you and it changes your behavior so I
think that there's a lot of behavior
change that just happens when when
people are terrified I mean you can even
in America where for cases you see you
know terror and and some crazy people
being held out of school because they
came from Rwanda or you know whatever
but so I think that's one reason I think
another reason is that you see moverá
small local outbreaks is what it really
is and in any household or or a block
you know there are people who are most
likely to be the caregivers and those
are people who are most likely to be
infected and and then after those people
are infected and dying I think you
naturally in that area you'll you know
you're running out of people who have
large numbers of contacts with very sick
individuals and so I think that's
another another part of that
the question is what do they do with the
bodies so what they do and actually this
is another reason why I think the
epidemic my in particularly in Monrovia
at least is decreasing is that they got
a lot better about responding to two
bodies and but I mean even when I was
there you know there were lots of Kate
you know you'd see people gathered
around and a team coming to remove the
body
but basically you know you have people
dressed in full PPE that come and so
there's a phone number you can call to
report a body and people will come in an
ambulance and spray chlorine all over
the body spray chlorine all around it
put you in one body bag spray that with
chlorine put you in a second body bag
put you in the ambulance drive you
outside of town and they've set up an
incinerator outside of town Oh
crematorium so every everybody who dies
in Monrovia nowadays with the exception
possibly of like children of members of
parliament or something like you have to
but essentially everybody who dies in
Monrovia now has that happened and they
go and and they're cremated in at night
there's they throw all of the bodies in
there together and I mean it's this
itself cause political there was a lot
of tension about this that you know the
family members have they don't get any
ashes back they don't get any there's
nothing that they get back so that in
itself is a disincentive to telling
somebody that your family member has
died but but you know anybody can call
about a body or whatever but you know
this is one of those tensions of how of
infection control versus anthropological
concerns if you want to call it that
great thank you very much great please
join me in thanking Richard for his